together in protest in a time of social
distancing
british airways staff threatened with
redundancy deliver a message
to their employer
at issue is an ultimatum from ba that
around 40
000 cabin crew and support staff sign
new contracts
that will cut the pay of many or face
being fired and rehired
with the terms imposed absolutely gutted
totally upset can't believe it a huge
pay
cut and a huge change in terms of
conditions
yes we are in a pandemic we're willing
to work with you
you're so hostile that these are the
actions you're causing
under the walls of windsor castle a
flight attendant with 20 years service
told me the new contract would cut her
pay in half
and force her to sell her home it's
really affected me to see my children
see me upset
it's what's hurt me the most how to tell
them that they can't get this and they
can't do that because mummy can't work
and it just has a knock-on effect and
the argument's among the family because
we're all under so much stress as it is
in this current climate this is just a
massive massive concern mentally
this letter from unite general secretary
len mccluskey has soured relations
further the union boss telling ba's
chief executive he was
both staggered and offended by your
arrogance
adding that they were moving towards
industrial action
with immediate effect a strike would
have achieved nothing when ba's planes
were grounded
but the resumption of 15 of flights may
have given staff and their unions
leverage
many of these staff believe ba is taking
advantage
of the kovid 19 outbreak to force worse
terms on them the airline says they are
reasonable changes
to allow them to compete with low-cost
airlines
aviation analysts say ba's long-standing
need to cut the costs of historically
well-paid staff
has been accelerated by the pandemic now
the time has come when
with the uncertainty faces in the market
it's great reliance on north american
traffic
it's reliance on profitable business
class traffic which is not likely to
come back anytime soon
it needs to negotiate the best
reductions in workforce sadly with job
losses
and indeed changes in working conditions
ba
says it will make 12 000 redundancies
and those that remain
have 10 days to consider its ultimatum
it could be a pivotal week
for a british institution and its
workers paul kelso sky news in windsor